madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal les risques de marée noire ne
sont pas totalement écartée après le
naufrage d'un pétrolier brise en deux au
large des côtes bretonnes
le plan polmar a été déclenchée pour
prévenir une éventuelle pollution
tous les membres de l'équipage ont été
hélitreuillés lancement de l'opération
samaritain parrainé par jacques chirac
pour la première fois des bénévoles vous
renforcer les équipes du samu social à
la rencontre des sans abri les fêtes de
l'an 2000 la fièvre des consommateurs à
l'assaut des magasins est prêt à
dépenser plus pour marquer se réveillant
hors du commun mais plus du sport la
finale de la coupe du monde de handball
terrible suspense à lillehammer cdh
après deux prolongations successives que
la france vient tout juste de perdre
contre la norvège
du jamais vu un match exceptionnel c'est
donc ce matin au large de la bretagne
qu'à pétrolier maltais s'est ouvert en
deux dans une mer déchaînée les
opérations de secours français
britanniques se sont déroulées dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et 26
membres d'équipage ont pu être
hélitreuillés
la cargaison de 30 mille tonnes est en
grande partie toujours emprisonnés dans
des sacs étanches du navire mais le
risque de marée noire n'est pas
totalement écartée nous y reviendrons
dans un instant mais d'abord retour sur
ce naufrage avec jacques devaux et
gabriel calmes hier c'est le plus
spectaculaire naufrage survenu près des
côtes bretonnes depuis 20 ans le eric à
un pétrolier de 180 mètres de long s'est
littéralement coupé en deux il a fallu
trois heures pour secourir l'équipage
indien composée de 26 personnes
finalement tous ont été hélitreuillés et
son sein ce canal hélicoptère est arrivé
et a pris cinq personnes quand il est
revenu le bateau s'est cassé en deux et
la partie avant s'est retrouvé à
l'arrière
nous avons paniqué nous avons vraiment
cru que nous allions
sourire j'ai prié j'ai pensé à ma femme
et à mes enfants vents de 100km heure
creux de 6 mètres
les conditions météo étaient très
mauvaises pourtant pour les sauveteurs
c'est surtout la panique de l'équipage
qui a compliqué la manoeuvre quand on
descendait la sangle plongeur est
réceptionné la sangle pour le hisser à
bord de l'hélicoptère
ils se battaient quasiment pour
récupérer la sangle plongeurs étaient
obligés d'en arriver aux mains pour
remettre de l'ordre
et maintenant la sécurité à bord des
bateaux à présent c'est le risque de
pollution qui inquiète les autorités
entre 1000 et 5000 tonnes de pétrole se
sont déjà répandus en mer
le pétrolier en contenait près de 30000
aussi le remorqueur abeille flandres at
il pris en remorque la partie arrière du
pétrolier pour l'éloigner des côtes
le convoi est maintenant le cap vers
l'ouest l'idée étant la suivante
éloigner au maximum cette partie qui est
la partie dans laquelle il semble y
avoir le plus de pétrole et surtout
celles qui fuient plus et semble que
donc cette partie il faille éloigner au
maximum et aussi vite que nous le
pouvons le préfet maritime a déclenché
le plan polmar il lui permet d'obtenir
tous les moyens tant civils que
militaires
pour juguler la pollution pour l'heure
celle ci ne menace pas les côtes
la nappe longue de 10 km et large de 5
et poussé par les vents vers le sud et
nous rejoignent en direct de brest
jacques cardoze et nous le disions à
l'instant le préfet maritime a déclenché
le plan polmar de quelle façon va t'on
contrôler la cargaison du pétrolier pour
prévenir une éventuelle marée noire
d'écouté finalement ici il y a deux
problèmes il y a deux parties du bateau
et les deux parties du bateau pose
problème d'abord cette première partie
celle qui flottent celle qui est
horizontale jacques devaux vous en a
parlé à l'instant elle elle commence à
être remorqué au plus loin des côtes
françaises des opérations débutées il ya
maintenant deux heures mais elle
progresse très lentement à raison de
deux kilomètres à l'heure une opération
qui va sans doute se poursuivre toute la
nuit probablement même une partie de la
journée de demain car l'objectif
vous venez de l'entendre et d'emmener
cette partie du temps caire au plus loin
des côtes françaises mais il y a un
deuxième problème qui est peut-être
encore plus important car imaginez vous
que cette deuxième partie du temps caire
est planté de façon verticale est planté
dans la mer et elle correspond à environ
un tiers des 180 mètres du temps caire
et de cette partie on ne sait pas quoi
en faire et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles le plan polmar a été
déclenchée parce que ce plan permet de
de mobiliser des moyens à la fois
nationaux mais aussi internationaux des
moyens techniques des moyens humains
alors comment ça va se passer bien dès
ce soir et dès demain matin un certain
nombre d' équipe de spécialistes vont
commencer à plancher pour savoir comment
on va bien pouvoir sortir cette partie
de la mer comment on va pouvoir
finalement la poussée elle aussi au plus
loin des côtes françaises et on avoue
ici qu on a absolument pas de solution
pour le moment il va falloir commencer à
travailler et on nous a dit également qu
on commence à être inquiet parce que il
faut bien dire que cette partie déverse
une partie de son liquide
on parle effectivement d'entre 1000 à
5000 tonnes de gasoil ici merci jacques
cardoze en effet ce temps coeur de 180 m
de l'an porte dans ses flancs vannes
4000 mètres cubes de fioul lourd une
très faible partie on disait c'est déjà
déversé dans la mer et si pour l'instant
le pétrole ne risque pas de s'échouer en
nappe sur les côtes les autorités
maritimes restent extrêmement prudente
car tout peut encore évoluer
deux paramètres difficilement
contrôlable la météo et la capacité de
résistance du navire valérie ermite des
vagues de la hauteur d'un immeuble de
trois étages
la tempête au large des côtes bretonnes
a des inconvénients et les avantages
l'inconvénient majeur c'est seul à
l'avant du bateau est à la verticale et
les remorqueurs ne parviennent pas à le
récupérer
combien cette partie contient l de fuel
personne ne peut le dire encore mais la
majorité du fuel semble être contenu à
l'arrière du bateau qui est actuellement
remorqué vers le large de ces citernes
du fuel trezeguet est en train de
s'échapper entre 1500 et 6000 tonnes
mais cette fois la tempête a des
avantages
la mère est en train de travailler pour
nous
heureusement aujourd'hui en dispersant
tout cela et en facilitant sa
biodégradation mais inversement il n'est
pas possible d'aller en mer travailler
pour confiner récupérer des nappes de
pétrole autre élément déterminant la
direction du vent un vent actuellement
de nord ouest
tant que le vent comme celle à l'heure
actuelle est au secteur nord-ouest
la nappe ne se rapproche pas à des côtes
néanmoins demain le vent va tourner
légèrement au secteur sud ouest ce
qu'ils font ce qui est un risque pour
demain mais dans la nuit de lundi à
mardi
de nouveau nous aurons du vent de
nord-ouest ce qui fait que à l'heure
actuelle on pense que cette nappe ne
touchera pas les côtes françaises
tous les moyens sont néanmoins mobilisés
car en bretagne le souvenir de l'amoco
cadiz est un cauchemar
une catastrophe sans aucune commune
mesure avec le naufrage de l'erika qui
contient environ 30 mille tonnes de fuel
l'amoco cadiz lui a déversé deux cent
vingt mille tonnes de pétrole sur les
côtes bretonnes
la france au delà des régions côtières
balayée par un vent violent depuis la
nuit dernière provoquant notamment dans
l'est de la france
d'importants dégâts et puis près de
nantes un pompier s'est tuée en tombant
d'un échafaudage renversé par des
rafales de vent le point patrick fandio
une chute de 12 mètres du haut du toit
de cet immeuble en chantier le sapeurs
pompiers de nantes est mort sur le coup
il avait pris appui sur une échelle mal
fixé il a sans doute été déséquilibré
par les violentes rafales de vents qui
ont soufflé sur toute la région
la nuit dernière un vent de sud-ouest
dont les rafales ont atteint jusqu'à 110
km heure dans la journée sur toute la
façade atlantique
impossible de sortir en mer difficile de
sortir de certains ports l'île d'yeu et
coupé des côtes vendéennes seul
l'hélicoptère assure encore la navette
avec le continent de 7h15 ce matin j'ai
eu une vingtaine d'appels jusqu'à
jusqu'à novare pour passer donc surtout
de les lieux sur le sur le continent
plus haut dont le calvados un
véliplanchiste a disparu au large de la
plage de luc-sur-mer les secours n'ont
toujours pas réussi à le localiser le
jeune homme est un professionnel de la
planche mais il aurait pris des risques
inconsidérés dans une mer démontée dans
les ventes sont de terre même si on a un
excellent niveau on prend des risques
surtout l'hiver c'est un coup va si on
casse de se retrouver au large ou avoir
des difficultés quoi plus facilement
surtout qu'avec une température comme ça
no chance d'être à l'aise dans l'eau
sont très vite diminué
les recherches seront suspendus après 22
heures pour reprendre à l'eau à l'est
c'est une rivière qui met en alerte tout
le nord du département de la meurthe et
moselle le cours de la chiers rossi
depuis deux jours alimentées par de
fortes pluies
la côte d'alerté largement dépassé le
niveau d'eau a atteint 3 mètres 20 et
rien n'indique une éventuelle des crues
il n'y a pour l'instant que des dégâts
matériels mais par prudence une famille
est déjà été évacuées par prudence car
météo france annonce d'autres pluies
toute la journée de demain aux açores
cet accident d'avion de la compagnie
locale sata l'appareil portugais s'est
écrasé hier matin avec 35 personnes à
bord sur une montagne d'une des îles de
l'archipel
ce matin les secours ont repris avec ses
équipes de recherche qui travaillent à
quelques 1000 mètres d'altitude et sous
une pluie incessante
apparemment il n'y aurait aucun
survivant les sauveteurs ont commencé à
rapatrier les premiers corps
le nouveau défi du samu social qui vous
le savez tout au long de l'année
sillonnent les rues de paris pour aller
à la rencontre des sans abri cette fois
ci pour la première fois de nombreux
bénévoles accompagnent sur le terrain
les équipes professionnelles
cette opération baptisée samaritain est
soutenu par jacques chirac qui assistait
tout à l'heure au lancement de ce
dispositif aux côtés des équipes de nuit
régulière des bénévoles vont depuis
cette semaine à la rencontre des plus
démunis patricia charnelet et maxime
nogier ont suivi l'un de ses véhicules
avec à bord des samaritains deux femmes
chefs d'entreprises qui participent à
cette action solidaire une nuits par
semaine pendant un mois une nouvelle
aventure commence pour ces équipes qui
depuis 6 ans vont à la rencontre des
plus grandes détresses pour la première
fois des bénévoles accompagnent les
professionnels de la santé
on sent qu'il ya quelque chose qui se
passe les gens se sentent beaucoup plus
concerné qu'il ya quelques années ils
ont envie de faire quelque chose c'est
la première nuit de ses bénévoles des
hommes des femmes de tous milieux de
toutes professions qui acceptent de
donner quelques heures pour les plus
démunis
vers minuit dans une rue du 6e
arrondissement rald a fait la
connaissance de monsieur dubois dans la
rue depuis 15 ans il refuse de suivre
les équipes du samu social
ils sont nombreux dans ce cas la mission
consiste donc à lui apporter un peu de
réconfort un duvet quelques provisions
en haute savoie en hiver pour possibles
conséquences
je gagne mes enfants et ma famille
ils ont aussi beaucoup de chance et je
me dis qu'il ya beaucoup de gens dans la
rue qui aimerait être aussi un petit peu
gâté et c'est ça qui me trottait dans la
tête
donc c'est ça qui me donne l envie de
descendre dans la rue d'autres sans abri
accepte le temps d'une nuit d'être
conduit dans un centre d'hébergement
il y en a qui m'appelle madame mais y'en
a un maintien des cours d'eau qui
peuvent aider
de l'exclusion de vraiment d'exclusion
de ce genre
leurs carences affectives il y à déjà
150 bénévoles
le samu social les appelle les
samaritains changé son regard changer
son attitude envers les exclus c'est
bien le sens de cette nouvelle étape et
de ce pari fou que personne ne soit
laissé de côté politique française la
décision de charles pasqua conforme à
ses engagements le président du
rassemblement pour la france renonce à
son siège de sénateur pour ne conserver
que celui de député européen choix qui
justifie par sa volonté de défendre la
nation française à strasbourg la semaine
qui s'ouvre sera marquée par cette
réunion sans précédent autour de la
situation de crise en corse de ma lionel
jospin à matignon réunit l'ensemble des
élus de l'île y compris les élus
nationalistes on peut s'attendre à
quelques échanges musclés à travers
cette première prise de contact présenté
par certains comme un revirement du
gouvernement qui avait toujours affirmé
que le dialogue ne serait instauré
qu'après la renonciation à la violence
l'enjeu de ce dossier ô combien sensible
arnaud bouteille philippe chasselas
vendredi les élus nationalistes observer
les employés de la compagnie corse
méditerranée manifester devant
l'assemblée territoriale
demain à matignon ils évoqueront ce
problème mais leur principale
revendication n'a pas changé depuis des
mois elle reste la même il faut que
paris renonce de façon définitive à
appliquer la solution policière ou
militaire comme une course je n'ai pas
le maintien de l'ordre eh bien
une question éminemment politique
fallait-il invités cordes cicada dionne
qui condamne timidement les attentats
sur l'île la question divise à paris
demande comment certains ont dit que
c'est un acte faiblesse du premier
ministre et moi je dis c'est un acte
sagesse la sagesse s'étaient quittés et
les élus qu'ils soient ici vous ont
convaincu pour le moment il ne m'a pas
encore convaincu parce que notre ont dit
qu'ils peuvent condamner des attentats
ce qui est évident la semaine dernière
peut arriver quand des attentats mais
comprend donne pas les auteurs des
attentats
lionel jospin a été clair que les élus
annoncent clairement ce qu'ils veulent
mais aucune proposition commune ne sera
présenté certains veulent parler
sécurité
d'autres brandissent l'identité corse ou
bien réclament une plus grande
décentralisation vu que jamais des
révisions sont d'actualité il était
possible de rester immobile il faut
avancer vers plus de d'autonomie vers
plus de responsabilité parce que les
neuf groupes ne peuvent se mettre
d'accord le débat pour répartir les
aides de l'état a été repoussé deux fois
même division quant à la politique
touristique
demain les propositions de changement
pour la corse devraient être nombreuses
lionel jospin et coutras et s'en tiendra
là
en grande bretagne c'est peu de dire que
la décision de la france de maintenir
l'embargo sur le boeuf britannique à
renforcer un sentiment anti français
pourtant la soupe à la grimace
entretenue par la presse ne résiste pas
à l'épreuve des faits comme chaque année
encore plus nombreux la proche des fêtes
du millénaire
ils sont des centaines d'anglais à
prendre le ferry vers calais pour le
marché des bonnes affaires benoît
duquesne
la journée s'annonce longue mais
fructueuse le réveil a souvent été
douloureuse vers 5 heures du matin mais
paraît-il ça en vaut la peine
et ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'on
part faire ses courses en ferry ce qui
donne à la faire un petit goût
d'aventuré on va acheter du vin côté les
vins sont un tiers moins cher sans
l'angleterre le boycott et la dispute
sur le boeuf c'est une discussion qui ne
regarde que les gouvernements est un
secteur très particulier du marché qui
est celui des fermiers et des éleveurs
voilà tout est dit ou presque et les
affaires peuvent commencer
car pourquoi attendre calais quand on
peut acheter des le bateau peu importe
alors que les prix soit un peu plus
élevé ici qu'en france les anglais ne le
savent pas ou s'en fiche leur frénésie
d'achat est telle qu'ils ne peuvent
s'empêcher de sortir les premiers
billets histoire de s'échauffer
je ne sais pas si c'est moins cher ici
mais j'achèterai aussi des choses en
france 1h15 de traversée par bateau 40
minutes par le shuttle à environ 500
francs la traversée ce sont plus de cent
mille personnes qui auront fait l'aller
retour sur le week-end car tous les
moyens sont bons pour atteindre la terre
promise ces montagnes de bière de vin
d'alcool en tout genre les choses
sérieuses vont bientôt commencer
et c'est parti boycotte ou pas on ne va
quand même pas résisté à des prix 30 à
50% moins cher qu en angleterre
même les grands de la distribution
anglais se sont installés ici ils ont
suivi leur clientèle elle va dépenser en
moyenne 2000 francs par les anglais
payer anglais et acheter parfois les
mêmes produits qu en angleterre
vous avez entendu parler de la vache
folle et du boycott sur les produits
français
je ne mange pas de bave je suis
végétarienne et tout le monde s'en
frotte les mains les anglais qui
achètent les magasins qui leur vendent
les compagnies qui les transporte et
bien sûr la ville de calais 40% du
chiffre d'affaires de ces commerçants
vient de là en fin de journée
les anglais repartent donc fatigué mais
content paraît pour fêter comme il se
doit nos ailes et le passage à l'an 2000
il sera toujours temps demain de lire la
presse populaire et ses appels vengeurs
au boycott des produits français
la capitale de la tchétchénie épargnés
jusqu'à cette nuit par les bombardements
russes pour autant les quelques quarante
mille personnes qui se trouvent encore à
grossemy se terre dans des abris de
fortune alors que la ville est
totalement assiégé depuis une semaine
les troupes russes cet après-midi ont
pris le contrôle de l'aéroport militaire
et paradoxalement dans cette situation
si menaçante des milliers de réfugiés en
ingouchie tente pourtant de rentrer au
pays
envoyés spéciaux dorothée olliéric
didier da les militaires une gauche
répondent aux larmes et aux cris des
civils par l'indifférence
les russes tu les innocents les vieux
ils voient lyon qu'ils ne sont pas des
combattants
on nous a dit hier qu'ils avaient tué
trois vieux les gens nous envoient des
messages de tchétchénie pour nous
demander de l'aide
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
les femmes ne passeront pas le barrage
la tchétchénie est au bout de cette
route mais seuls quelques bus de
réfugiés dûment enregistrés seront
autorisés à passer
certains ont dû payer pour rentrer chez
eux dans leur tchétchénie en guerre là
bas c'est vrai c'est la guerre mais il
vaut mieux mourir à la maison chez nous
y'a que de crever de faim ici la fin
mais aussi le froid et surtout
l'humiliation de la vie de réfugié
pousse les tchétchènes à rentrer chez
eux par milliers demain d'autres
quitteront encore ce camp de toile pour
rejoindre leur village tchétchène
désormais contrôlé par les troupes
russes
vahid a quitté greuze me il y à un mois
avec femme enfants frères et cousins
l'attend 71 est devenue sa maison ici
vivent 27 personnes vahid lui n'est pas
prêt à retourner en tchétchénie sa
maison à grozny n'est plus que cendres
le cauchemar est encore trop proche
je ne veux pas faire revivre aux enfants
tous ces bombardements
je n'ai plus confiance en personne je ne
peux pas faire ça c'est pas possible ça
suffit pour nous mais j'ai enterré temps
de jean de matha n'a jamais reconnu
officiellement les bombardements aériens
sur grozny sont suspendus jusqu'à ce
soir minuit
ce qui signifie que l'offensive russe
pourrait reprendre dès cette nuit le
cessez-le-feu devait permettre aux
civils de sortir de grozny très peu
l'ont fait à partir de demain ils
devront respecter certaines heures pour
sortir entre deux bombardements ou alors
rester terrés chez eux à grozny au chili
se déroule depuis ce matin les élections
présidentielles l'enjeu de ce scrutin
est de savoir qui dirigera demain le
pays en lice un ancien conseiller
d'augusto pinochet est à l'opposé un
socialiste qui pourrait être le premier
président de gauche depuis salvador
allende
maryse burgot c'est effectivement la
grande décision
le chili choisi aujourd'hui qui de ces
deux hommes sera le prochain président à
gauche un socialiste à droite un
conservateur ex collaborateur du général
pinochet
le candidat de la coalition de gauche
s'est lui dit ricardo lagos très entouré
ce matin à l'ouverture des bureaux de
vote
les sondages le donnent gagnant mais
seulement au second tour
s'ils l'emportaient ricardo lagos serait
le deuxième chef d'état socialiste a
dirigé le chili après salvador-allende
allié devenu un mythe
depuis qu'il fut renversé par le général
pinochet lors du coup d'état de 73
profils diamétralement opposés celui du
candidat conservateur
jack sim lavine fut un proche conseiller
de bus tôt pinochet pendant les dix sept
années de dictature mais comme son rival
socialiste il a scrupuleusement éviter
pendant toute la campagne d'évoquer le
douloureux passé du pays les chiliens
ont de toute façon relégué au second
plan de leurs préoccupations le sort du
général
l'ex-dictateur est depuis un an en
résidence surveillée en grande-bretagne
les deux principaux candidats aux
élections présidentielles ont donc
préféré évoquer les problèmes
économiques plutôt que l'embarrassant
cas pinochet
venons en maintenant à l'histoire de ce
couple homosexuel britannique décidée à
avoir coûte que coûte des enfants parce
que la justice anglaise n'a pas autorisé
ces deux hommes d'affaires richissimes à
adopter ils sont partis aux états unis
et grâce à une mère porteuse dûment
rémunérés ils sont devenus cette semaine
les deux papa de jumeaux reste à savoir
si la justice britannique reconnaîtra
leurs droits parentaux
rien n'est moins sûr anne consignes et
ils sont deux heureux papa baril et toni
32 et 35 ans les voici dans une
maternité américaines là où rosaline
bellamy vient d'accoucher des enfants
qu'elle a accepté de porter pour eux de
forte seulement car ils ne sont pas
d'elle ils ont été conçus in vitro à
partir d'un ovule anonymes et des
spermes des deux hommes eux seuls savent
lequel des deux est le père biologique
marie et tony partage depuis 11 ans une
vie prospère
s'ils ont eu recours à ce système
moyennant 2 millions de francs c'est que
leur demande d'adoption avait été
rejetée en grande bretagne les juges
américains eux ont accepté d'inscrire
les enfants comme ayant deux paires
d'accord on est homosexuel
mais on aime penser qu'on mène une vie
normale comme celle d'un couple
hétérosexuel normal
la chambre est prête à recevoir les
enfants la justice britannique un peu
moins elle ne refuse pourtant pas par
principe l'adoption aux couples
homosexuels mais elle ne prévoit pas
pour le moment la situation légale de
deux parents de même sexe
en france le réveillant de l'an 2000
suscitent la fièvre des consommateurs
partis à l'assaut ce dimanche des grands
magasins apparemment pour ce noël et se
réveillant du coma les français seraient
prêts à dépenser plus beaucoup plus
cyrille devaud nadine picard les enfants
le centre déjà le père noël sera encore
plus généreux que d'habitude alors ils y
ont préparé une liste de cadeaux plutôt
longue et les grammys docteur maboule
allen téléphone
les cubains les gros culs de deux
poupées une poupée qui parlent ils
poupée qui cela c'est le cas pour ce
noël exceptionnel les parents dépensent
beaucoup plus que les années précédentes
de 6 à 8 cadeaux par enfant deux mille
francs en moyenne par famille
la star des ventes cette année c'est
furby la peluche interactive 260 francs
elle partage la vedette avec sa copine
l'hôpital un + 30 % de ventes pour les
ordinateurs caméscopes numériques ou
lecteur dvd des cadeaux qui peuvent
dépasser dix mille francs mais rien ne
semble trop cher pour les fêtes de l'an
si on pensait dépenser 500 pour un
cadeau les parents eux aussi veulent se
faire plaisir pour le réveillon les
femmes surtout s'accorde quelques folies
18500 fonds pour cette robe blanche aux
éclats de cristal d'être forcément
baisse ce soir là le sort de l'an 2000
s'avère important pour tout le monde
donc effectivement le budget
et peut-être plus importante pour six à
halak pour les hawks à la vente de
tenues de soirée a augmenté de 20% par
rapport à l'an dernier dans ce grand
magasin les français l'ached aussi les
cordons de la bourse sur les produits de
fête pas question d' économiser sur le
champagne le foie gras même si les prix
commencent à flamber plus de 10 millions
de clients sont attendus dans les grands
magasins parisiens un tiers soit dit
prêt à dépenser beaucoup pour que ces
fêtes fête inoubliable
mais noël des animaux 2000 avec que la
campagne de la spa pour l'adoption de
ces animaux qui attendent dans des
refuges
depuis hier deux journées portes
ouvertes pour encourager les français
qui veulent un animal de compagnie à
choisir plutôt la spa que les chenils où
les magasins alain double ce qui est
manuel bec
il fallait du courage ce week-end pour
affronter la grisaille de gennevilliers
en banlieue parisienne
ou alors comme ses visiteurs une bonne
motivation soixante mille animaux ont
été recueillis cette année par la spa
c'est à dire 50 r 1000 chiens et chats
souris lapin 180 80 moutons 35 chevaux
mais fanny ses deux soeurs et leur mère
c'est un chien qui recherchent
ces animaux sont soient recueillies sur
la voie publique soient abandonnées par
leurs propriétaires
ce petit où tout va séduire funny c'est
sûr c'est sûr pourquoi tu es prête à
sortir à nettoyer à t'occuper de lui à
faire tout et corvées way joue turin
jugnot ça y est le coup de foudre a eu
lieu d'ailleurs ça ne marche que comme
ça il y aura quelques papiers à remplir
pour adopter il faut fournir pièce
d'identité justificatif de domicile
fiche de paye et verser 800 francs pour
un chien 900 francs pour un chiot de
moins de six mois
ensuite passage chez le vétérinaire de
la spa
il fait le point sur tatouage
alimentation dressage et vaccins sont
arrivés hier laissant son carnet
on voit bien que si ce chou avait pu
donner son avis sélectionner ses futurs
maîtresse il aurait choisi c'est le
jeune fille
l'événement sportif de la journée se
déroulait sur notre chaîne en direct il
ya quelques instants avec la finale de
la coupe du monde de handball à
lillehammer pour la première fois
l'équipe française féminine était en
finale
un incroyable suspense les françaises se
sont battu pied à pied contre l'équipe
norvégienne
il a fallu jouer deux prolongations
successives où tout était possible à
chaque instant pour finalement
s'incliner avec un seul but d'écart
devant les norvégiennes nathanaël de
rincquesen
elles ont perdu la finale mais pas leur
sourire l'équipe de france de handball a
frôlé l'exploit ce soir à lillehammer au
terme d'un match incroyable
le secret de cette équipe de france si
sa solidarité pour battre la norvège
soutenue par onze mille supporteurs les
françaises se présente en formation
serrée dès le début de la rencontre
valérie nicolas la gardienne fait des
miracles en 33 matches la france n'a
battu la norvège qu'une seule fois
les bleus n'ont rien à perdre alors l
attaque et ça marche
en première mi temps les françaises font
la course en tête
elle se détache et compte jusqu'à trois
buts avance
les norvégiennes sont dépassés sur sa
ligne valérie nicolas semble imbattable
la deuxième période se résume à un duel
de gardienne les parades spectaculaires
succèdent aux arrêts miraculeux
à une seconde de la fin du match alors
que les deux équipes sont à égalité la
france à l'occasion de s'imposer mais le
tir de miharu est une nouvelle fois
stoppé jusqu'au bout du suspense
jusqu'au bout de deux prolongations
la france se bat mais finit par craquer
score final 25 24 les norvégiennes
n'osait plus y croire
el harrach pourtant le titre mondial à
la france qui pense déjà à la revanche
l'an prochain auger thiney
la france n'a pas été gâtée par le
tirage au sort pour l'euro 2000 les
tricolores devront affronter dès le
premier tour les pays-bas demi finaliste
de la coupe du monde la france se
retrouve dans le groupe d le plus
difficile de la compétition
florent gautreau andré germain roger
lemerre a trouvé des camarades de jeu
coriace pour le mois de juin prochain
le sourire est un peu crispé car le
tirage au sort a réservé à la france les
pays bas la république tchèque et le
danemark
trois anciens champions d'europe bien
sûr les bleus ont échappé à l'angleterre
ou à l'allemagne
mais ils devront affronter l'un des deux
pays organisateurs
les pays bas avec à leur tête l'ancien
joueur franck rijkaard font figure de
favoris quatrième de la dernière coupe
du monde les pays-bas possèdent l'une
des équipes les plus enthousiasmantes
d'europe et une pléiade de joueurs
talentueux
à commencer par dennis bergkamp joueur
d'arsenal et auteur d'un but
exceptionnel lors du mondial 98
les coéquipiers de berck amp réussissent
plutôt bien aux français lors du dernier
championnat d'europe
les pays bas avaient été éliminés par
les bleus aux tirs au but en quarts de
finale mais le 21 juin prochain
la hollande pourra compter sur le
soutien des 70000 spectateurs de l'arena
d'amsterdam s'est pas toujours un
avantage de jeu chez soi a eu bien
négocié leur premier match mais c'est
vrai que les pays bas comme la belgique
qu'on l'avantagent quand même du sol du
terrain
la france est difficile mais après tout
ce serait intéressant et ce sera un
superbe match pour le public c'est déjà
ça
la république tchèque rappelle de
mauvais souvenirs aux français en demi
finale du dernier championnat d'europe
les joueurs d'aimé jacquet avaient été
éliminés par cette équipe surprenante et
accrocheuse les tchèques qui ont gagné
tous leurs matches en éliminatoires
seront toutefois privés contre la france
de leur meneur de jeu patrick bernière
qui sera suspendu à cette occasion mais
le premier adversaire des français le 11
juin à bruges sera le danemark une
petite nation toujours présente dans les
grands rendez vous en 92
les danois avaient remporté le
championnat d'europe à la surprise
générale
pays bas république tchèque danemark
trois équipes ambitieuses
les français ne pourront pas dire qu'ils
n'ont pas été prévenus au châtelet pour
les fêtes de fin d'année la troupe de
maurice béjart mais elle affiche
casse-noisette de tchaïkovski revisité
par le talent du chorégraphe à spectacle
conçu comme un album de famille georges
bégoux abdes viège dans les années 30
maurice béjart fait partie de ces jeunes
baigneurs des plages de marseille
il garde la nostalgie de ces temps
heureux et de l'amour infini le sommaire
ma mère toujours me mère divinité et
souvenirs devenait à chaque excursion
plus grande plus belle
une vingtaine est plus mystérieuse seul
élément de décor une femme déifié
symbole de sensualité de fécondité une
roche bienfaitrice que l'enfant ses
vertus escaladé sans y parvenir
c'est un ballet qui s'il est presque
tout seul dans le sens que j'ai pas
voulu dire ça mais ça fait ça il n'y a
pas de message bien gosse est ce qu'il
fallait c'était retrouver sept ans l'âge
de mon pseudo l1 mais raymond et avec
sept ans raconte que l'histoire comme
une bande dessinée infantile il se
souvient par exemple des corridas dans
les arènes d'arles ou de nîmes
m
il se souvient de ses études classiques
à londres où il a pris les règles de
marius petipa l'inventeur du ballet
romantique
et puis paris la valse musette et la
java apache de la rue de lappe il a fait
appel pour cela avec bonheur à yvette
horner et son accordéon
et
enfin la célèbre valse des fleurs que
maurice béjart traite avec l'espièglerie
d'un potache à travers des personnages
porteur de toutes les ambiguïtés
en revisitant le plastique ballet
casse-noisette béjart nous livre les
images télescoper de sa mémoire d'enfant
miss france 2000 est âgé de 18 ans une
jeune femme métisse et qui a fait avec
ses parents le rwanda en 1994 au rwanda
où elle est née depuis sonia rolland
s'est installé en famille en bourgogne
région de naissance de son père sa
première dauphine est miss provence ce
sont les téléspectateurs en partie qui
ont participé par leur choix à cette
élection c'est la fin de ce journal
rappelle les principaux titres les
risques de marée noire ne sont pas
totalement écartée après le naufrage
d'un pétrolier brisé en deux au large
des côtes bretonnes
le plan polmar a été déclenchée pour
prévenir une éventuelle pollution
tous les membres de l'équipage ont été
hélitreuillés la finale de la coupe du
monde de handball terrible suspense à
lillehammer site après deux
prolongations successives que la france
a perdu avec juste un point d'écart
contre la norvège du jamais vu un match
exceptionnel dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet à 20h55 juste cause
avec sean connery 23h45 le dernier
journal france duprat de masse dans cinq
ans dans les 4 vérités française laborde
recevra pierre moscovici ministre
délégué chargé des affaires européennes
à 20h vous retrouverez claude sérillon
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2